there has been an unbelievable amount of
venture capital investment flowing into
health tech companies what started out
as a lot of direct to consumer companies
is now really shifting into the back end
and so why is this it's because the
infrastructure this sort of piping
dealing with
these administrative problems that
aren't the sexiest but they're really
important to other businesses wheel is a
digital health company that has two
components
so the first is a staffing component and
the second is back-end technology for
other companies to be able to stand up
their own telemedicine practices digital
health companies need to be able to have
doctors and nurses other providers who
are licensed across all different states
think of it kind of like
a gig economy solution like if you use
uber and you call a driver and then the
driver is going to be there soon wheel
is doing a similar thing but saying i'm
a patient i need to talk to a doctor
i'll match you with a particular type of
doctor or nurse or whoever it is that
you need for your particular problem
on the back end side they have something
that's called white labeled which means
it doesn't say that wheel is doing it
but a company could start offering
telemedicine services by using wheels
technology the founder of wheel is
michelle davey and so first off there
aren't many
women founders and ceos in healthtech so
the unique thing about michelle
is she founded this company that's
really for the back end it's enterprise
it's serving other digital health
companies and
that's something that makes her stand
out
i actually started my career in
healthcare due to my past so i grew up
in a rural part of texas and
unfortunately went undiagnosed with an
autoimmune condition for over 15 years
and so for me access to care has played
a really large part of my life when i
first started my career i went into
healthcare to change it and quite
frankly i
became a part of the really big system
that healthcare is working for really
large companies and quickly realized
that i was looking for something a
little bit more fast-paced than the
antiquated healthcare system that i was
in at the time telehealth was where my
personal
life of rural community living and
access
to care collided with
the
professional background i had built in
recruiting and operations when trained
to build in healthcare everybody was
building the software
in these fragmented worlds but really
nobody was thinking about the clinician
and the supply part of this that are
actually the backbone of delivering this
care altogether
so building in healthcare pre-pandemic
in austin was probably not obvious to
many in fact a lot of silicon valley
people had told me eventually to have to
move my startup there to really grow it
and scale it over time i think the
pandemic really blew the walls off of
where we could build in healthcare and
why
these tech hubs are actually good places
to build there was a lot of great talent
maybe not in healthcare but they were
coming from other applicable industries
that were scaling and growing everything
from fintech to retail attack all across
the board and so for me it was very
important not only to build wheel here
in austin as a healthcare company
because of my personal background and
access here in texas but because of the
local talent we were building we all in
2018 before it is obvious that a supply
and demand imbalance were coming to
virtual care but to me it was obvious
that it was already happening in
in-person care it was really hard to
access doctors wherever you were at you
know you oftentimes patients were
waiting two to three weeks sometimes
months at a time to access doctors in
person we didn't know a global pandemic
was gonna hit only two years later but
when it did the reality of the supply
demand imbalance patients seeking high
quality care from the comfort of their
home or wherever they were at and
clinicians working in a whole new way
really solidified almost overnight
access to care is something obviously
near and dear to my heart and so our
clients across the board look very
different i think what's really
interesting is most of our customers
have been delivering virtual healthcare
for less than two years so this is a
very new industry a very new service in
the market and quite frankly we all had
to convince a lot of people that this
was the new way to build in healthcare
wheel has raised 66 million dollars and
in 2020 the company's estimated revenue
was 8 million dollars
now wheel is expecting really
significant growth they expect to be the
back end for
one million patient visits and that's
five times the number in 2020. there's
really a lot of opportunity for
companies like wheel because we're gonna
see
just explosive growth in this back end
software space because that's really the
direction that the industry is headed